bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors d'abord vous avez
entendu jérôme rodriguez qui a été
interpellé de façon musclée ils
expliquent ils il avait rejoint le
cortège des contre-manifestants qui
faisait face donc ça n'a pas duré
longtemps à une manifestation de
génération identitaire sur cette journée
précisément votre analyse alors tout
d'abord rappelé et il n'y a pas de
violences policières
si il ya des actrices sont isolés ils
sont sanctionnés minoritaires et n'a pas
voir du systémique soit la police
d'avoir rappelé le soutien aux forces de
l'ordre qui exorbités une situation très
compliquée on l'a revu encore cette
semaine avec le cas de la taca à poissy
donc le ce que les propos qu' une de
monsieur reid et senans langage que lui
qui aura une enquête a priori suite à
ses déclarations et qui portent plainte
mais voilà je vais rappeler que très
solidaire des dépôts volant qui est dans
une mission une mission qu'elle est très
compliqué difficile au quotidien sur la
manifestation d'aujourd'hui locales de
génération identitaire et la contre
manifestation
la manifestation la coupe une plantation
en décembre des antilles faa été
interdite par par le par le préfet par
le préfet de police
donc c'est normal que cette
manifestation ne soit pas tenue
l'essentiel est de préserver l'autorité
et l'ordre par whoopi comment une
manifestation qui est un territoire elle
pu se tenir alors même de gros risques
de débordements est on là
potentiellement vue lorsque les lieux
une un rapprochement et forme de contact
entre les ratios identité les antifas
c'était c'était important j'ai toujours
d'éviter des accrochages et des faits
qui auraient pu être dit l'amour qui va
peut être relativement violent mais sur
les images quand même que l'on a vues
pour revenir à l'interpellation quand
même d'un jérôme rodriguez même dans le
cadre d'une manifestation non autorisée
quel regard vous portez sur la manière
dont lui a été justement interpellés
ne trouvez pas que c'est un petit peu
excessif la manifestation était
interdite je fais toute confiance aux
forces de l'ordre qui exercent qui
exercent leur métier pour justement
éviter
une situation qu'il faut le rappeler
était très très à risque avec des
annonces d'affrontements et des appels
de lens qualité qui avaient été portées
broad sa a raconté côté de l'extrême
gauche allait évoquer cette inscription
d'extrême droite
je pense que le l'essentiel a été
préservé on peut se rappeler il ya
scènes d'émeutes et de chaos que nous
avons vécu l'automne dernier avec des
antilles faille des black blocs ravagé
le mobilier urbain où on avait des
scènes deux quasi guerre civile dans
paris moi je me réjouis que ce soir et
on n'a pas eu ce genre de scène
aujourd'hui
justement le l'ordre ring la
manifestation qui se déroulait dans le
calme sur génération identitaire menacée
de dissolution par gérald darmanin là
votre analyse
je trouve que gérald darmanin et fort
avec les faibles et faible avec les
forts
c'est à dire qu'on a un groupe qui est
plutôt plutôt pacifique qui amène un sur
le débat la question laquelle dell sur
le développement de la question de
l'immigration et on va préférer plutôt
s'attaquer à ce groupe s'il y amène une
question qui appelle le débat puisque
78% des français estiment qu'il faudrait
passer une immigration subie vers une
immigration choisie donc un vrai besoin
de débattre de cette question va
reprendre le contrôle de notre politique
migratoire choisir quel est le rapport
au nord en vue d'appliquer et on a le
sentiment que finalement on veut
supprimer le débat sur cette question la
cour pour faire disparaître les
problèmes les interrogations que ça ne
réglera strictement rien
est ce qu'il est dans son rôle est-ce
que génération identitaire est dans son
rôle lorsqu'elle ya des actions anti
migrants mener comme ça a été le cas
dans les pyrénées c'est ce qu'a
d'ailleurs reproche le ministre de
l'intérieur a à l'association anti
immigration
c'est des actions point de communication
justement très rare parler pour l'heure
comme ils l'ont fait ce qu'on a pu ce
qu'on a pu voir en a pas eu de décision
de justice les condamne ans je suis
quand même assez assez étonné dans le
même temps que des générations comme là
africaine nous ce n'est pas été dissoute
alors que les appels à l'élite et les
propos plus que douteux c'est un peu un
deux poids deux mesures où finalement on
s'attaquait de son extrême droite mais
en même temps on a une forme de
complaisance vis-à-vis des associations
d'extrême gauche
est-ce que tout va céder les actions que
même génération identitaire sur le
terrain qu'elles sont légitimes et ce
qu'elles sont et ce qu'elles sont
légitimes ou non il y apporte une
réponse du moins il faut entendre une
voix sur la question de l'immigration
sur le débat qui actuellement d'un pas
lieu et c'est l'essentiel dans le débat
sur notre politique migratoire il le
fait de reprendre le contrôle de se
doter des outils d'appliquer ou non une
politique migratoire que demont
restrictif donc ce débat là n'aura pas
lieu
mais justement ces actions est long le
bien fait de porter le débat et de
décider de faire parler cette question
là lorsque la pire des réponses essayer
de te mettre cette question là sous le
tapis alors que les français veulent en
débattre veulent apporter des réponses
et ont besoin justement de choisir lors
de reprendre le contrôle de leur destin
et de choisir leur politique migratoire
est ce que vous pensez que la
dissolution de génération identitaire
peut porter un coup justement au débat
sur l'immigration dans la mesure où ce
n'est que 1 était d'un millier
d'adhérents peut-être moi même
l'association entend tél
je pense que cela aura de l'impasse
pacifiquement mais c'est un coup porté
sur le sur le débat sur la logique dans
quel dans laquelle agit le gouvernement
certaines questions et certains sujets
ne veulent pas être abordés on l'a
notamment vu avec la question du
séparatisme des amendements sur le port
de voile ont été refusées manière
systématique il ya toute une série de
sujets de thèmes qui sont sciemment
évité chevaux que celle plus dommageable
et la discussion générale quand il fait
partie de ces actions qui mènent à
activer le débat merci beaucoup à vous
america glissé je rappelle que vous êtes
à le directeur de communication du think
tank le secrétaire général partant du
secrétaire général adjoint du think tank
le millénaire
voilà merci à vous